I
me is bearded guy number two Alex Lucas
hey guys so we've had a lot of technical
difficulties today and we apologize for
that basically you know there is no
excuse I have no excuse either scrum
ones I screwed up maybe maybe I
overloaded the power maybe I just
angered the gods and by God's I mean
rato but we are on live on YouTube doing
the via android games review rato Meyer
is behind the console doing awesome
stuff and hopefully making everything
work we've got Andy's brand-new I'm
sorry no it's brand-new to us it's
Andy's old camera um I think you threw
it away because you know he only spent
like 10 grand on it and why right why
even keep it and it's more than like two
weeks old so there's something that
we're awesome by now exactly so it's a
broadcast quality camera now does that
mean that we are broadcast quality not
even or not no not close but we do have
an excellent beer today we are drinking
the mckellar beer geek brunch yeah so
this on the on the teaser for this we
promised you CAD droppings and the tie
in there is that this is oatmeal stout
made with coffee that has passed through
the intestines of civet cats good thing
you brought your towel yeah who's for do
it is by the way I'm just going to do
this it looks totally gay but you
literally can't do that with these
levelers better no yeah so it's holiday
style day your hoopy frood I try to be I
can tell you yeah you have your towels
so if you need any other necessities
which you may have forgotten I'd be
happy to help you out and you know in
celebration of doing the game review I
made sure to get a game theme to towel
that is so awesome is you know Mario
themed nice also this is the first time
today literally the first time that I
have
jinnah mirror all day so like wow you're
doing pretty good I really AM ruggedly
handsome all right let's get to the
games awesome so I think we're going to
go ahead and start off what was your
favorite game I think by far this week
my favorite game was invasion of the
veggies okay should we start with that
one or you want to save it to last well
with your second favorite game second
favorite would probably battle loot
let's take a look at battle loop that'll
look looked pretty good to me okay so
let's go I go to the tablet it's so one
of the Isle of that sheep yeah that is
that is pretty sweet they have you sold
pretty quickly with that she by the way
I the unfort
Oh
it's good by the way I had a talk with
the YouTube tee and they said they're
cool
you
okay all right well we're we're done
with the cover assmann maneuver that was
necessary let's go back go ahead and go
back to the tablet take a look at battle
loot adventure apologies for the low
resolution today I know the video is
sort of weird off the tablets because
for some reason we can get the hdmi to
work today so rather than delay the show
while I frantically you know did stuff
like rebooting the computer which has
always worked before I don't know why we
went ahead and decided to just put this
on a webcam so that's how we're looking
at it I know we're getting a little bit
of temporal distortion and that the
resolution isn't quite as good but we'll
be able to play the game anyway and you
can see my fingers look should I be a
hand model no why don't you do this you
know I probably shouldn't you a hand
model either but sure alright so battle
loot is at its core a turn-based RPG
game it's actually a pretty reminiscent
of if you've ever played any of the
final fantasy games let's random
wondering and it seems to it skips the
wandering around and talking to people
in villages and it's pretty much a
series of battles one thing I do like
about is the battles are they managed to
avoid sort of what I call the final
fantasy trap of making a battle mode
that revolves around a long series of
sub menus so you can see in order to
attack this little gremlin looking dude
here I just double tap them someone
jumps in attacks but what if you need to
use a special ability I've actually
gotten far enough in the game that have
special ability so what makes sense
because I mean that's that's the final
fantasy thing right it's you've got so
many special abilities and definitely
you want to like cruise past a menu of
all your special abilities before you
get something simple like you know sab
right what's that actually I think stab
is a special ability is it I don't know
I never really played final fantasy i
only watch my roommate play it and it
looks like working I to me it was a
really cinematic
second games I enjoyed them but they
kind of they all went on too long I
never actually beat a final fantasy game
I just got two-thirds of the way through
and then like a year passed my grades
have dropped and it was just time to
move on see this is this is why you're
working at Google and my former roommate
is not right I've also never played
while in my entire life wow that was
good alright alright so so how is the
sound by the way it's a iLike it the the
sound effects are pretty fun the the
background music is cool as you can see
or I hope you can see it has pretty good
production value the graphics are really
neat yeah I really like the style it's
it's cool it's fresh you know when I was
looking at screen shots at first I was
worried that it was sort of a castle
crashers clone because it had sort of
that cartoon anything but uh the game
plays is uh it's entirely different like
for one thing being turn-based mm-hmm
and yeah I really like it so there's a
little bit of you know what I call the
five-minute illustrator effect going on
where yeah you can see that they've
pulled in a bunch of things you know a
bunch of vector art and then just kind
of animated it together you know right
um we're none of it's really changing
its just sort of moving up and down
exactly exactly but I think I'm gonna
give this one a pass because it still
looks pretty good and they've got a lot
of pieces like some games you'll see
well actually only have you know one or
two moving parts i like what you know we
reviewed a game a while ago that the
only thing that moved was like the
monkeys tail right and it didn't move
very convincingly either so and you know
nothing about it was actually a really
fun game but the production values just
weren't quite as high this one I think
it's all right I like it um they did
have let's say they had one sort of
prerequisite fail which is just that
there was music over the lock screen
that is so common it's really difficult
you have to remember that music needs to
be shut down when the when you get a
non-stop or and on pause but we
you get a non resume that's not your cue
to resume music the reason is that a lot
of times the resume will be sent to your
application while something like the
lock screen is still active now we're
actually changing this in jellybean I
believe you know you never know until
until it actually drops what's going to
be in the release but but we've talked
about it and we think you know would be
nice to actually send the resume after
the phone is unlocked but you know for
the next year or so anyway you're going
to want to make sure that you wait for a
non resume and you also wait for your
window to regain focus and what a lot of
people will do I think this is the
absolute best solution is don't even
worry about watching for these messages
when when you're trying to decide
whether you want to resume music or not
instead when you get an on pause just
pop up a pause screen and taut and stop
the music and then don't restart the
music until the user dismisses that
screen that is absolutely the best way
to do it because you know music over the
lock screen is really really annoying
but the core question is what am i doing
when i unlock my phone you know the
problem is i play a game but i use my
phone for other things i use my phone
for business I so I go into a meeting
last thing I was doing was playing a
game I pull my phone out now certainly
if the music plays over the lock screen
that's terrible cuz i got unlock the
thing while you know it's playing
dudududududu or whatever you know I was
gonna sing a particular song from a
particular game but then I realized no
no because the man have to mute us again
rato would meet us really i think this
towel is probably toeing the line rato
actually has us on a five-second delay
and his hand poised over a giant red
button marked mute I really wish he had
a different button marked beep so that
we could swear like belligerently and to
those to her I thought that's what the
mute button was for it's what it's more
effective if there's because we could be
discussing you know confidential things
and he would have to match the mute in
time but if we deep it sends a signal we
are swearing exactly jellybean is going
to have
anyway we're going to go ahead and and
talk a little bit more about the the
adventure game here okay so so some of
the other games over reviewing this week
have sort of fallen into this trap to
one of the advantages that this game has
is being turned based nothing's actually
happening in the background during can't
lock screen this is you can tell it's
just it's kind of waiting things out if
we go back to the menu let's see how
many clicks this takes it is a little
bit confusing to figure out how to get
back to the menu okay why is out and
since we need to hit the back button you
hit the back button okay the back button
it goes is pausing yeah and that's
actually you know that that's sort of
what we've recommended many times is it
you know we hit the back button you you
might want to bring up a pause menu we
actually stopped recommending that and
the reason we stopped recommending it is
because exactly this problem where you
see the menu that's popped up is
actually quite complex it's the in-game
pause menu but it doesn't feel like it
doesn't really give you a way to go back
and that's really what the back button
is for is to go back right so if it's if
it's just the way that you launched some
completely new different and complex
menu where it's not even obvious how you
would return to a previous state that's
probably not the best thing to attach
the back button and it's especially in a
game like this right because as you said
nothing's happening when when you're
playing a turn-based game that is no
different than browsing your email or
you know news reader or whatever have
you um it shouldn't have to do anything
special or different than what an
ordinary Android app would do so for a
game like this the back button should
really just take you back yeah as long
as you have some way of also going
forward again that's really the key
there's no forward button on Android uh
but they're they're almost should be
right you always want to be able to get
back to where you were whether it's you
know up in the back stagger down
okay actually bring up a good point
let's test that out so not really sure
how to get back to the no I don't know
yeah we want to let's just hung out and
go straight back to the home screen and
then re-enter and see where we end up
well I hope we'd end up in the same
place right i mean that's that's kind of
what's supposed to happen well you do
yeah awesome okay so that's what we want
yeah maybe I don't know it's oh so we're
paused and then there's a pause button
over here what does that do oh it stops
us from being pause yeah okay right so
so yeah it's it's effectively the exact
same as the back button yeah and you
know this is this is one of those
examples of things where we we kind of
ratchet up our standards as time goes on
so it used to be that the main thing we
wanted you to do was not disable the
back button and everybody got that
message and this is awesome and this
game is doing a perfectly fine job of
making sure that the back button works
and you know it adhering to everything
that we said was policy last year not
policy but you know recommendations
right this year we've taken a look at it
and said you know what we should really
go a little bit further I and and as I
said this is why we we don't have any
idea I guess I'll maybe I'll hit the
quest button that doesn't do it the uh
oh there we go quest and then quit see
event that's a little confusing it's not
with that I would not have guessed that
yeah it's not an intuitive UI my main
critique of this game would honestly be
the navigation to different states
inside the game like it's not really
intuitive you don't know where you're
going at one point in the game like when
I was testing this before before the
review i leveled up and it said
something new in the armory go visit the
armory no clue how to get to the armory
oh that's rough no see you know that's
the thing yeah and every one of those
notifications should be actionable this
is the really important thing whenever
in and you can think about how you feel
when you see a notification in the
notification bar on your device you know
you pull down the notification bar you
see all these little things how would
you feel if you clicked on or tap down
one of those
and it didn't do anything right some
notifications don't that's terrible feel
like something's missing the
recommendation is yet when when you
notify the user sunny or say hey you
know here's this thing you need to know
about you need to be able to take some
action right at that point and you
should give the user a button to just do
it yeah yeah all right so other than
that I mean the game here is beautiful
it's absolutely stunning I have a really
hard time believing that this isn't a
professional team yeah so what I would
recommend I think you may have gotten a
little bit too into the game yourselves
you might have played it just a little
bit too much it probably makes a ton of
sense to anybody who's played it for
even just a more than a few minutes but
to the casual user that's just picking
it up it feels very confusing and that's
a real problem i'll tell you why android
it supports a huge number of
applications do you see how I save that
because I was going to say android
market right both but I didn't Google
Play is full of games and while many of
them are not filled with wonderful
production values a lot of them are a
surprising number of them are they're
beautiful they're wonderful they're
worth your money and you've got to stand
out you know I remember going to a talk
by Brenda Braithwaite and John Romero
and they mentioned and they were talking
about in the context of social networks
but I think this is true on mobile as
well that if you didn't grab the user in
the first night of it was like two
minutes or something if you didn't grab
the user in the first two minutes
they're gone you're dead to them because
they have a hundred other apps that they
could be looking at so you really want
to grab the user you want to make sure
that the game feels safe to them it
feels understandable it feels like they
can get something done and they can go
kick some ass and get whatever reward it
is that your game gives them in the
beginning you don't want to drag it out
or make them learn
something because you know it's it's not
1985 anymore I didn't just save up my
entire months allowance to go and buy my
new Commodore 64 game that I'm gonna
play for another month because I don't
have any money to get another one I'm
kidding i pirated all my converse 64
games who didn't anyway I got number
munchers legit hey wow you're awesome I
have a hard time believing you even know
what a Commodore 64 is Alex what are
you'd like 12 he has a beard okay see
this now i'm jealous now ask him what a
BBC micro is no clue something by the
way this beer is excellent it's quite
it's it's like a shot of espresso filled
with Wonder and not just know I wonder
what's in this espresso that is not what
I'm wondering all right the keys you
can't let it get get luke warm because
it is both beer and coffee yeah so it
has to be cooked hot yeah or not in the
middle or it'll be like awful i'm like
an order of magnitude worse than just
lukewarm beer or absolutely it'll be
illi it'll go bad possible cat thing I
think really adds a dimension of danger
to the hole right yeah you don't want to
get that Luke war that's a that's a bad
bad idea so back to the back to what we
were talking about the point is you've
got just a few minutes to impress your
user so make sure you make the most of
them all right other than that I mean
certainly I'm impressed by the graphics
right the gameplay actually seems really
fun you know I'm on the I'm on the verge
of wood recommended for future I feel
like yes it needs a little bit more of
in game navigation so you know what
you're doing inside the game like how to
get to the armory how to exit out to the
menu so that you don't just play from it
and a half get confused bail out and go
play something simple instead well you
know what i think i'm going to do and we
just want to talk about this a little
bit because there is some confusion
online before about this we're going to
nominate this to our
our android game review board and what
that means is it will go into a list of
games that are being looked at by a
group of people they're all volunteers I
you know we buy them beer and we set
them down with a bunch of games and say
hey you know play these games tell us
what you think now these people are
experts it's a lot ruf work yeah exactly
well you know you have to do these
things I it's either that or look at
apks for porn right we're it's it's so
we're committed some yeah you kind of
split your time right yeah well I'm a
you know I put in that extra fifty
percent good job I don't wonder you got
promoted so thanks anyway only put you
on this list and a bunch of very skilled
people a lot of them have worked for
years in the video game industry they
come from all over the place basically
just got tired of making video games and
thought hey I'll you have google a shot
and of course they just got right in
because video game programmers are
awesome and like beer and like free beer
yeah that's that's pretty much the draw
don't you think so when these people
look at your app they're going to
scrutinize it for several of things we
talked about on the show yeah buttons
shame and the back button issues
navigation resolution for tablets and
things like that but the main thing
they're doing is trying to figure out if
the game is fun and if it's going to
appeal to a lot of Android users and if
they don't feel that it's worthy of
being featured they will enter tons and
tons of texts as long as we stand behind
them with whips and make them enter it
and we'll send that to you in general
now this sometimes takes weeks because
quite honestly there are a lot of games
to look at all the time and on a good
day we burn through maybe twenty twenty
I think yeah I think that's our record
20 is our record for games we got
through today right for this review
process yeah anyway all of which is a
long way of
saying when we say that will send you
some feedback or that will nominate you
for featuring in general we won't be
able to do that the same week because
what we do is we put it in the queue we
mark it as something that we talked
about on the Friday review which makes
it automatically a pry one which you
know we get to after the prize zeros and
then once once we get some feedback then
we can send it back to you so this one I
think is worthy of that process I think
we should talk to talk to the review
board we see what they think see if they
can think up some some excellent
feedback for us and this is work really
well in the past you know for instance
let's talk about my favorite game that
we've talked about on the show which is
gunman clive i love gunman clive i think
it's just a cool game we took it to the
review board and they said you know
there's a lot of good things about this
game here's some things that we would
fix they made some you know a few
suggestions some of which were
reasonable some maybe not so much we
took that back the developer went back
and forth for a week or two on email and
eventually gunman Clive was featured
just couple weeks ago so that's how we
work here all right let's go ahead and
take a look at the next game so I think
we want to maybe maybe a puzzle puzzle
to HD I should point out to you guys
before you get started it's fully passed
so you probably only have time for one
or two more games wow wow we talked a
lot today you know what the problem is
no clock yeah no clock in front of there
used to be keep us yeah before we did
get to the next game i really want to
plug i just found out about this today v
because we may sail oh absolutely yes
yeah we've been working with those guys
for a while I the because they may guys
because we may I is a collection of
independent game developers who are
doing a sale on every platform where
they can set the prices themselves
because I can right there are some
platforms Google Play is not one of them
are some platforms we can set your own
price so there is a greater what day is
it I think it's running right now okay
through June something great yeah this
is a whole
bunch of people a bunch of games from
the Twitter feed a bunch of independent
games that we had looked at in the past
and loved right I think what did I be
like 10 or 20 titles so high I think 20
plus yeah so a lot of my favorite song I
there's like World of Goo there was
Ozma's again but I think I doin Clyde
was on there yeah and they're all just
celebrating the fact they can put things
on sale whenever they want absolutely
yeah you're in charge of your own
merchandising Ryan because i buy these
games i also want to celebrate that they
can put this stuff on sale whenever they
want yeah don't I buy those games for
you though you do yeah but you do for
the ones that we review but in there but
when I'm late to the game and it's
already been featured hmm and so yeah
that's rough I'm left to my own devices
so anyway go ahead and check that out
because that is an awesome sale and we
really want to support independent game
developers you notice we we're really
strongly committed to helping
independent developers and not just the
gigantic corporations that everybody
hears about so whenever we get a chance
to feature some great independent titles
that have some really cool qualities we
like to do that oh you know who else is
on there chicken banded hidden bandage
this is this is one of my favorites I
met these guys at GDC and the keynote
ask a question they said they asked if I
could give them any advice on how to
better market their games i said well
tell me about your game they said okay
there's a cowboy riding on the back of
the giant chicken so the soul like I
right there off the game like that's all
they needed to say to anyone
you know so it's a fun game it's a
little bit awkward to get used to the UI
but it's a lot of fun to play and the
premise is a cowboy in the back of a
giant chicken yeah I mean it looks kind
of like a Commodore 64 game a little bit
yeah like the good kind of Commodore 64
game oh absolutely if I'd had that
friend converse before I would have been
really impressed yeah absolutely okay we
want to just cover a couple more games
right the list lightning round right be
drowned so let's go through a few of it
so for instance I so this is a neva
defense negative fence negative i think-
defense all right I I love the guy i
don't know if you guys saw his post on
Google+ but he he mentioned that he was
doing this because he wanted people to
be prepared for a missile attack which
i'm not sure where this dude lives or
what his life is like but i think that's
pretty boss yeah unfortunately it's all
I black screens so you're mostly looking
at the reflection of our webcam can't
even see those plane okay let me around
okay so negative defense was really
interesting not like not like super high
production values but very cool game you
should check it out right all right I
definitely say invasion of the veggies
oh we need to look at that chair if area
this is actually my my favorite game
from the sweet and skips it this is
actually also the only game this week
that managed the lock screen and the
back one both perfectly alright i was
really happy with who is a developer i
don't remember um basically look there
are vegetables it's a ballistics shooter
it's a ballistics here oh but it's not
like it yeah it's not like a ballistics
physics puzzler like i was sort of
expecting you know it's a ballistics
both six tower defense basically we're
not tower defense no that's that's cool
and as the game goes he's gonna yet have
a little time II I'll lead your guy yeah
loading and reloading shoot three in the
upper reload I think you can get a
bigger bucket of cherries I guess these
onions are super Tanya as an upgrade I
can understand this because I I love
fruits and hate bills as well so what
see what was that oh I button by mistake
I thank you right away hey you know so i
was talking to I i was talking to
matthias a couple days ago and he was
talking about exactly that thing they
actually were talking about maybe moving
some of those buttons in future version
of the OS just so you wouldn't they
wouldn't be so easy to hit them during
gameplay nice to avoid some button
mashing I think we got actually question
developer office hours on Wednesday it
said is there a way that I could move
like the helmet back when to the top of
the screen so I don't have people
accidentally drop out and the only
answer we could give him was no but
maybe you can render your entire
application upside down and which is
sort of that is a that is a wonderful
answer and while you're at it put your
cabs on the bottom you know why cuz
that's what rato Baggins hates okay can
you pass me that bottle because you know
the truth no no the one that's full of
beer not the one that's empty 30 because
honestly I cracking this open and
pouring it in my coffee mug was the only
good thing that's happened today so high
of you can talk back to the screen real
quick I've got like I really enjoy this
game the only nitpick I have and like I
would definitely not make this to the
board investigate for featuring this
isn't a block or anything but just as a
critique the upgrades don't describe
what the upgrades are until you can
afford them so this guy this strawberry
it says not enough money I've no idea
what the value of the strap know what I
love that I love that you like yeah I
love that because it keeps you guessing
like it's I i like that it shows you
okay it's strawberry it's not not just
like you know a picture of a lock or
something i hate that but you think to
yourself oh my god i want that straw me
what the hell is that strawberry do and
it better be it better be something
awesome nice job 80
oh if I if I yearn for that strawberry
for weeks until I earn whatever dollar
amount it is at that strawberry cause
grand maybe that's strawberry pass
through the dietary tract of that tattoo
that's possible yeah if I if I yearn for
the strawberry and save five grand to
buy that strawberry it better do
something incredible that's all I'm
saying but yeah it's it's really cool to
have things I think that you're
interested in you know part of games to
me or is discovery I can see that yeah
anyway yeah different strokes good folks
yeah still definitely a fun game let's
see what else oh this guy though this is
this is an interesting game it's a
survival based game called deep trip
that's a as you can see there's not much
in the way of a menu you just sort of
skip straight to the game let's see when
when I heard that we were reviewing a
game called deep trip the last thing I
expected was a game about eels the UH
the background music is the background
music is catchy the game is simple the
play of the graphics or is it as catchy
as whale trail it's no but but it's fair
to compare something that's different
yeah it's just it's so pleasant I've
talked a lot of people to have played
whale trail but have never gone to
youtube and checked out the video and
you need to do that yeah we don't
usually plug other Google products on
this show but well it's not whale trails
on a Google product no you tube is
alright youtube give them some views so
what they do is they make an entire
music video and it's like the Beatles on
so the Beatles were on acid so what what
would you have to go what do you have to
do to get further than that you need to
explain the whale trail yeah I i don't i
don't know i don't know how whale trail
happened by the way this show contains
alcohol and drug references parents
should be supervised
hmm that's some great coffee with beer
in it all right so uh but it but it is
sort of a survival runner right and you
know up and down in type of game so so
similar to panic flight or wheel trailer
a lot of yeah how do I sell a couple of
the lifecycle stuff okay for instance in
mid-game if you hit back no menu you
just disappeared out of the game well so
what happens if i go back in oh I get a
loading screen and then I start over
yeah oh that blows yeah and they're uh I
mean this is a minor thing can be fixed
the one thing that they did that I would
consider Cardinals saying is that after
you leave the game for the first time
there's a notification that pops up that
says hey check out our other heyzap
James okay and that's no it's
notifications or advertising no no hay
so it's a notification in the
notification area in the new relation or
when you're not okay game it's a snail
Kotchman for other games Wow well so
that is better than asking for system
alert permissions and then you know
showing a system alert dialog right but
you're toast in the middle of a
different game yeah yeah you don't want
that so certainly if you need to notify
the user or something the notification
bar is the right place to put it but
yeah I think I would get a little pissed
off to the thing is a notification we're
like you said it's for when the user
needs to be alerted to something it's
not like when we even say in the Android
design guide it is not a place for oh my
god they haven't seen our brand in five
minutes we need to fix that really so
remind me again why we did
cloud-to-device messaging but for games
now but yeah this is true i mean a lot
of people do use notifications to
promote the brand and I yeah it's one of
those things like direct mail you know
everybody says they hate it but it must
be working on somebody right yeah but at
the same time there's a look as you know
as a member of developer relations like
I won't nominate until that goes away I
agree and as a user if the game is going
to be irritating to me even when I
playing it it gets uninstalled well no
that's very true you you know saying hey
you haven't played my game in 20 minutes
is a great invitation to either play the
game or uninstall it so it may or may
not be a good thing yeah so we have the
developer of invasion of the veggies on
the stream and here he is hopefully said
that he can fix it so that the user will
be able to see what the upgrade actually
does even if he doesn't have enough
money so the question is should he make
that change oh well I think that
maintaining a little air of mystery is
fine I think it's a cool idea but it's
really up to you see I'm of the opinion
part of the strategy is like okay here's
a powerup it's two thousand dollars
here's a powerful it's 5,000 do you want
to sue dads and right I want to know do
I save up or going to splurge on it but
it but if you but if you don't chant
information it's like a my whole thing
right do you want to keep it or do you
want what's behind the door but what if
what's behind the door sucks or
shouldn't say so sometimes it does
that's why but let's make a deal with an
interesting show hey rato have you
watched let's make a deal how about you
right you probably know let's make a
deal from the Monty Hall paradox in your
statistics class I do I'm so old I also
watched the game as a kid so I think it
can be an interesting thing but like I
said we haven't actually bought these
power-ups we don't know what they do
they better do something amazing right
you know you want to have something
that's really cool if its just oh you
know does 10 more damage then the grape
or whatever yeah lets you know maybe you
should just say that right out yeah but
if it's got something really cool about
it yeah Ian and I are on opposite ends
of this one but I would say to do some
research like I said this is not a deal
breaker it's like oh we would have
featured it but I didn't know what the
strawberry did
that's never now now now you're right
yeah we're described all in here we're
arguing amongst ourselves and its really
like it that was like the one nitpick in
this game that I was like that's less
than awesome for me like everything else
it was a lot of fun and yeah I like the
beating back the angry hordes of carrots
you know what I'm gonna say this i think
it's worth trying it out yeah i think
you know the the aura of mystery
intrigues me but i don't think i would
miss it right right so if you have the
chance to change it i think i would okay
I really do and that's just not just me
caving under to you and your towel clad
body it's it really is anyway yeah I
would say go for it yeah that's not that
takes us to 256 at 256 is an excellent
time to close down thank you very much
reto Meier for being a stellar stellar
producer I think somebody said this
should be your day job and I heartily
agree because you suck at everything
else absolutely it's a pleasure the
pleasure is always rato is awesome he's
the face of Android developer relations
were very lucky to have him as producer
today he's extremely attentive all the
titles have gone up all that all the
scene changes have happened correctly
devil horns have not appeared over
either of our heads we haven't actually
seen the stream remember we only see
what rato chooses to show us hopefully
you won't use the TR that was on
Wednesdays office hours you guys don't
watch the YouTube stuff off but we've
posted it right I do now this I've been
this one right I'm watching it by the
way do you see our names in the correct
places oh no they're in the wrong place
nice i'm glad i was saying when you put
the titles together today hmm you're
right i should have sat on the other
side mmm looks on the spot we don't when
we asked nature hey can we do a practice
shot he's like oh no we're live now like
that's ever stopped us before Oh
it's time for us to go actually we need
to go crack the whip on the Android game
review board we've got to go take notes
and ask them to give more justification
and all sorts of things so and we need
to carry the beer over the other
building so it's been wonderful to have
you join us thanks very much for tuning
in and we will see you next week for
another Friday game review thank you
very much guys